Paris County Judge Edie Emmet is calling
on citizens with boats to help with
water rescues the county judge is the
chief executive for the county and its
request comes after he discouraged
people in Houston from evacuating Friday
before the storm hit this is not an
event you can call for evacuations a
hurricane you know the storm surge is
coming and the coastal areas need to be
evacuated but exactly which
neighborhoods might or might not flood
tonight or tomorrow night
we don't know Emmet is also director of
Harris County's office of homeland
security and emergency management he
joins us by phone good morning good to
have you here good morning are you we're
awake I'm well we're waking up this
morning after more rain overnight how
dire is the situation oh the situation
continues to be very very extreme and
the first responders has done a great
job of trying to get people out of
harm's way with help from ordinary
citizens who have pitched in with boats
and high water vehicles now the issue is
as they continue to bring people out of
the flooded areas we have people who are
stranded that they brought out to
shopping malls and schools and now we
have to have the logistical means of
getting them and supplies to the relief
shelters so that we can begin to take
care of these people and get their lives
semi back to normal I'm hearing from
from friends I know here in Houston her
mom and dad on the second floor of their
house with their dogs there have got to
be hundreds more stories like that do
you feel like you have the resources you
need I don't think anybody could have
enough resources to deal with this now
the state sent in assets they were very
helpful very cooperative but the roads
are all impassable so it wasn't until
late yesterday that Texas Task Force One
was able to even arrive and staged their
equipment we are able to now use that
today and that will be very very helpful
but with interstate highways closed as
roads are closed just being able to get
into some of the
neighborhood is the difficulty do you
have any update on casualties I don't at
this time it's been miraculous that
there haven't been more the early
casualties one is too many but appears
to be a handful and most of them were
related to being in vehicles and driving
into high water which is why we didn't
want people on the roads as if they then
unfolded scale you understand some of
the injuries that you're dealing with I
saw a very touching piece this morning
where someone was helping a woman rescue
from the water and he said listen if the
water is very cold but don't worry we're
going to be here to help you don't worry
about that and I hadn't really thought
about the temperature of the water what
kind of injuries are you dealing with
we're seeing well of course anytime
people are trying to well let me back up
first we encourage people to stay in
their home if at all possible because
going out into the flood water is
dangerous debris is in it manhole covers
come off and you could fall in you don't
know what the terrain is under your your
footing and so there are injuries that
are just going to happen but right now
you know my concern is these first
responders have been doing this now for
two days without rest people are really
beginning to get worn out and whenever
you get that tired then it makes it even
easier to injure yourself any idea
what's in the water and you know if your
body stays in contact with it for too
long and if you ingest it what do you
tell people when it comes to making that
decision do I go or do I stay well we
always say if at all possible stay in
your in your home if the water such that
your life is threatened and of course we
state down 9-1-1 but the 9-1-1 system we
have three major 9-1-1 call centers city
of Houston and Harris County and they
were overwhelmed with people calling for
help I had people calling me directly
who happened to know my cell phone and
they'd say listen there's a woman who
has gone into labor and such
such place can you help get her out we
have 4.7 million people living in Harris
County and of course the surrounding
counties the overall region at about six
and a half million so it's just a
massive massive dire situation you make
a very good point about the work that
the first responders have been doing and
how tired they must be and that's why
you're calling on volunteers to help a
man was watching the news he said listen
I was sitting home watching you guys and
I thought let me get out there and help
I'm an able-bodied man
so how critical are the volunteers to
this effort absolutely critical and and
not only those who can come out and help
with the rescue we're sending up so many
shelters people can go fallen tear in
those shelters to serve food to provide
supplies and interestingly enough the
schools are all closed for the entire
week so you know the kids that are old
enough take them let them help too this
is something that neighbor to neighbor
just we just have to pitch in and help
each other okay thank you very much
judge Edie Emmet there Harris County top
official when it comes to public safety
we appreciate the time good luck to you
thank you thank you